poor honor finally they had closed alpha
um we've been hearing about this people
been like searching for it a lot and
asking about it a lot but we finally got
to play it did it line up with your
expectation what did you expect it to be
and did it line up with your
expectations I feel like I was a little
surprised by I've been wanting to play
it like you said there's been interest
at least for me to want to play it and
it kind of shocked me at first it was a
little bit I guess more defensive in a
way than I thought it would be I'm sure
gonna be offensive but you know there's
there's definitely more mechanics going
on than I thought there would be and
definitely with no blocking left
blocking right blocking high and then
kind of like countering or like
countering a grab or countering a guard
break so there's a lot of like I don't
want to say it's rock paper scissors
necessarily but there's a lot of kind of
that kind of going on and I didn't
necessarily expect that and so I was
kind of explaining or describing it when
we were doing our Elijah sharing that it
was kind of frustrating at first because
all I want to do is kind of you know go
at them but it's a hate bring of dar
souls but you know it's like you kind of
learn by playing the game like oh I
can't play this way I better learn how
to play the mechanics of the game and
kind of master those I haven't mastered
those yet necessarily but I could see
how if you can make the right reads and
there's like a probably like a pretty
decent meta game going on like that can
be really fun it's just do you want to
put the time in to kind of learn those
like kind of subtle nuances learn the
move sets of the four classes for each
faction and kind of how they flow how
they fly so you know how like you can
kind of see where they're going to
attack from but it's not always
necessarily the case which so it's like
timing your parries and all that stuff
so I think that's pretty cool to me it's
just I don't know if I'm gonna spend the
time to come and get really good at it
unless like I play more in the office
and then people start whipping me in the
office they don't kind of get triggered
yeah no I totally agree with you I think
the people that take the time to master
defending and like you know you see this
thing pop up it's like this trifecta you
can go black right left up and then
different character classes so there's
like three races and then
each one has two variants fighters I was
playing the like the samurai ones a lot
the heavy and the light and after a
while you start to see the stance at the
other players are and that's what how
you know whether if they have like it
raised over their head like okay i'll
attack the right or left if the night
has it like kind of to his left eye was
the tack overhead I feel like that plays
into it but I felt like I definitely
played better when I was a little more
patient if possible I did try button
mashing and you could tell the people
that were button mashing we're also kind
of just ignoring how I think Ubisoft
wants the game to be played so I think
over time I'm worried it might lose
players that aren't really committed to
like learning it because it definitely
has a very strong learning curve I think
I just assumed to be a third person
action game when you're in the middle of
these hordes of like minions and adds it
sits like a dynasty warriors game you're
plowing through them right but when
you're actually fighting the like the
heroes the other players that's when it
becomes like what we thought for honor
would be and then like speaking of
dominion mode right here with this so
there's three capture points a B C a and
C are just normal capture points that
you get four points to like add up to I
think a thousand and then you get the
chance to kill the other heroes and go
in but the B is like this tiered zone
where you help your your creeps push
forward into the enemy territory you
take it and then anytime you want to
capture you have to actually have your
creeps advance so that's where like
almost MOBA esque yeah when i'm going to
play the other interesting thing too is
in these four before skirmishes it's
also how good are you kind of
communicating with your teammates
because you might tv1 someone and it's
actually really tough at least when we
were playing or when I because I've only
played a couple hours but to really
stave off two people at one time you can
you can kind of generally direct in
block in one direction and that
sometimes will get them both yeah they
kind of pinch you it's pretty hard to
kind of defend both points so you kind
of gotta you know maneuver around your
territories also maybe just run for help
sometimes gotta watch your stamina
obviously so that plays another factor I
think it's like all three on one I'm
screwed yeah no it's definitely about
placement as much as anything like more
than just the fighting because flanking
is a huge deal if you don't even see
someone come up behind you they just do
like an overhead like heavy attack in
your
I don't know like the more I played it
the more impatient i got but maybe
that's just because I wasn't giving it
the chance to actually kind of teach me
because there was a tutorial beginning
there's a lot of things that like I
didn't really completely grasp like
there's a guard break which of course
works if they're guarding but if they're
not guarding it doesn't do anything yet
it kind of leaves you like there's not
much you could do against it if they use
it so there's a counter to the counter
break how do you come back it's like you
hit X oh really I think it's like X or a
I forgot which forget which tutorial
watching ps4 xbox one but there is a way
if you can see that they're gonna do the
guard break because the little shield
icon think I'm pops up you can kind of
quickly hit that button and and stop it
but it's like a reflex thing it's like a
you know sure and then there's also like
baiting people you know kind of like
going to your left's and so they think
you're going to attack on the left and
then just switching to the right really
quick and attacking there it's almost
kind of like the threat of what you're
about to do can be more dangerous than
what you actually do obviously the
threat isn't what's gonna throw an axe
into your head but you get what I mean
in the essence that it's a mind game
after a while like you said I I don't
like when you get out number but I think
that's the point they don't like it's
that's like the ganking I guess well
there's that revenge mechanic too which
is supposed to kind of help you deal
with two people I saw people employ well
and kind of killed two people at the
same time if you're not using it
properly or don't really not understand
how to use it properly you could also
just easily die so I I'm actually
interested I didn't get enough time to
watch other streamers but I want to see
what really good players look like and
what that kind of gameplay looks like
and then see if I'm kind of motivated by
that and like oh wow okay there there's
all these the mechanics coming to life
the way that they see it and I could
maybe play like that too but when you're
kind of going in even though there are
really good tutorials just kind of hard
to see some of that stuff because of who
you're fighting at one oh yeah
definitely and it feels like it's almost
odd that I don't want to set not
disparaging Ubisoft I like a lot of
their games but it seems like you know
like when you think you saw a Assassin's
Creed and you think of like Tom Clancy
games you think of things are gonna be
safe somewhat but then you have like
rainbow sixties it came out it was just
like very tactical like high skill
ceiling multiplayer make a for honor
that's coming out that's kinda
the same thing it's like player versus
player focused very high like you know
easy to learn difficult to master kind
of thing and I don't know that it's not
like a trend coming out of the entire
publisher but it's still now that we
know more what it's like it's intrigued
me but I again I just don't know that I
can really mount that skill ceiling and
kind of like get over the first few
hurdles to actually really enjoy the
game and like like it for what it is
we've only played a brief amount of it
I'm solis in February yeah I mean sorry
to cut you off there but I'm also kind
of curious about what that campaign
looks like we saw kind of a brief will
snip it at e3 is it kind of one of those
that's shorter but gives you like a kind
of like a story kind of thing for the
for the factions or is it kind of more
in-depth we haven't we don't know yet
obviously so I'm interested in that
maybe the campaign kind of spurs you on
to play multiplayer no hard yeah yeah
definitely I mean release in February I
believe yes yeah I think so cuz I got
pushed back it was originally earlier
but I guess every game was pushed back
now but you know why you could play
bushido blade right now is that a
comparison you by making yeah we shuda
blade I'm one into PlayStation fighting
games where it was like one-on-one sword
duels and there was no health bar mhm if
someone's sword hits your arm you lost
your arm you just had that one other arm
to fight with someone cut your leg you
died and it was this great dueling thing
because it just captured the reality of
like what these impacts could do and it
would just restart a fight like that so
you could like have these sort of like
rapid like duals like that really do
like teach you like you gotta learn what
you're doing or you're gonna die
captures a lot of what I think this is
going for but without all the clutter of
modern gaming demands that things must
have if it comes from Ubisoft it has to
be this big like bushido blade is it
pure dueling game and that's out you can
play that right now yeah because you
could just do one on one and for honor
you do 2v two then the minion modes the
one with the creeps and everything I
think that's when I had the most fun
with only because I wasn't completely
married to the mechanics of the game
even though i think mechanics do feel
good i just don't think i gave it the
chance like to like I gave myself a
chance to really learn and respect it i
guess i don't know but yeah I don't know
so now I'm intrigued by the game for
sure that releases in February of 2017
on ps4 xbox one pc and yeah
check it on the future we'll have more
coverage on gamespot